[Musique]
les cerisers sont blancs les oiseaux
sont contents revoilà le printemps
oui je dors mal dans mon lit ma cousine
est trop jolie la ou est normal maman ce
délicieux tourm qui fait rougir tout le
temps oh tu roug encore Dom si je me
Maria est-ce que tu me compais moi alors
vraiment
va Paul Paul pa il y a pas de soucis
comme ça le petit Paul Paul Paul est
trop petit pour ça le petit P c'est
encore un gamin il Jobie il court dans
le jardin ne pense pas au fi m mooi les
ceris y son Blant et c'est très énervant
d qu'on est un peu grand
coi ah ne te fâche pas j'ai plus l'âge
de jouer à
à à là bébê qui monte qui monte qui
monte qui monte
maman les cerises sont BL les oiseaux
sont
contents les cerises sont blanc les
oiseaux sont content ma
cousine je
suisé je suis un homme
et quoi bonjour comment tu vas ta coiure
s passe
à
il te fche
pas Paul Paul c'est l'heure de t'on
goûter oui vaen Paul Paul va s'inquiéter
tire-toi Paul va jouer au qure CIX va
jouer au va jouer à rien avec tes
petites clotettes les charers sont
les je suis pas cont
j'aurais jamais cru ça elle savait
jouer comme je te
[Musique]
dis son blan et j son
content